[Music]
this morning we continue our ion
innovation
series on the increasing role science
and technology play in our lives
we're learning how horseshoe crabs could
play a key role in the development of a
vaccine for the coronavirus
but scientists are increasingly
concerned about their survival
tom hansen shows us the fight to save
these extraordinary animals
[Applause]
each year from maine to mexico
guided by the moon countless horseshoe
crabs complete an
annual journey older than the dinosaurs
one that is crucial in developing a
covid19 vaccine
these animals have been on the planet
for over 445 million years
give or take a week or two in there this
is a living fossil
yes it is that's the mail scientist john
tanacredi has dedicated his life to
studying these so-called
living fossils pretty active very
healthy that's good
he runs the center for environmental
research and coastal oceans monitoring
program
at molloy college the largest horseshoe
crab breeding lab in the western
hemisphere
his team tracks 115 beaches around long
island
they say the horseshoe crab population
is in dire straits
how much time are we looking at here
before we
lose horseshoe crabs i'd say the next 10
years
the next decade is of a critical concern
critical concern not just for the
ecosystem
but also for modern medicine
pharmaceutical companies have relied on
these prehistoric creatures for decades
to the dismay of conservationists it's
all because of how their blue blood
keeps them safe a unique feature that
helps scientists quickly detect
deadly bacterial toxins we recognize and
most people recognize that this
is a valuable resource john is an
executive director at charles river
laboratories
it's really represents you know lots of
evolution
and the horseshoe crab blood is
exquisitely sensitive to these endotoxin
pyrages
you've likely never heard of these
dangerous toxins but it all started with
a professor at johns hopkins university
named dr frederick bang in 1956 he
observed a horseshoe crab become
naturally infected with vibrio bacteria
and then witness the crab's blood
actually clotting around that bacteria
when they're in the shallow water
they're awash these bacteria
so if they get injured the amoeba sites
recognizes these bacteria they recognize
it as
an opportunity of infection so they clot
that reaction became the basis for this
test
which checks for bacterial contamination
in any medical product that goes into
the body
before the manufacturer ships them out
including iv
drugs heart valves and yes vaccines
we have a 450 million year old creature
that for the last 45 years
has improved the safety of medicines for
humans and animals
in the u.s limits have been put on how
many horseshoe crabs can be harvested
each year
and while the humble horseshoe crab
cells can be removed with no apparent
harm to the creatures
studies show biomedical harvesting over
fishing for bait collection
and coastal development are causing a
drop in the population
raising major questions about their
survival
there is a public concern a real concern
about these animals
that we lose their habitat or we lose
them coming
to shore once you lose them they're gone
extinction is forever
but with a global push for a coveted 19
vaccine underway
horseshoe crabs are once again in the
spotlight which tanacredi hopes will
help
conservation efforts if enough of people
can hear about
it and talk to it that helps in getting
the attention
this has been going on long before a
pandemic
has issues and concerns for these
animals and and our health
so i'm optimistic
you have to be for cbs this morning
tom hansen west seville new york